le chanvre le cannabis ça fait sourire
n'est ce pas on pense aux hippies dans
les années soixante à woodstock ou bien
les restes en jamaïque qui passent leur
temps à fumer des pétards et avec guet
pourtant la très sérieuse
wikipedia nous dit que le cannabis c'est
le nom latin pour le chanvre il nous dit
également qu'il est cultivé partout sur
terre il est cultivé des montagnes
arides du maroc en allant jusqu'aux
plaines de sibérie est évidemment en
bretagne comment est ce qu'on peut
savoir si c'est bon si c'est pas bon on
a deux molécules principal dans le
chanvre cannabis
on a acheté le thc le
tétrahydrocannabinol il est interdit
il est dangereux pour la santé est
également consommé par cinq millions de
personnes en france
ça fait beaucoup en il est champion un
petit peu quand même d'europe ce sujet
line aux molécules qui le cbd le
cannabis violent lui est pas
psychoactifs cannabis qu'on appelle le
cannabis thérapeutique
il contient des molécules qui sont
étudiées de plus en plus il n'est pas
interdit voire même plébiscitée par le
seuil haut si on revient un petit peu en
arrière dans les années 2000 je suis
professionnel de santé et j'ai envie de
d'isoler ma maison avec du chanvre
on met deux hectares en culture à la
torche près de quimper
pour isoler ma maison
également je vous avoue avec un projet
de faire des planches de surf en chambre
on l'a réalisé aujourd'hui
ensuite lors d'un repas de famille
j'apprends que mes grands parents ont
cultivé une année du chanvre quand ils
n'avaient pas de graines de lin que mes
arrière-grands-parents cultivés de
chanvre est dans une espèce de mémoire
cellulaire s'est emparée de moi et j'ai
vendu mon commerce d'optique pour me
consacrer à la culture et au
développement de la plante
on se retrouve donc encore en arrière
dans le passé bien avant mes grands
parents
ici c'est ce qu on leur apprenait
l'école en 1900 voilà la carte de
géographie vous rappeler l'épisode est
qu'on mettait la sueur sur les tableaux
eh bien regardez en bleu qu'est-ce qu'on
a la culture de chanvre en bretagne
pourquoi parce que les conditions
climatiques étaient favorables un peu
d'humilité le matin de la bonne terre et
un savoir faire
ce savoir-faire nous a amenés à avoir
rendez vous compte cent mille hectares
de chanvre en bretagne d'après le
cadastre napoléonien en 1853 cent mille
hectares 25000 tisserand travailler pour
mille personnes travaillent et où vivait
de la culture du chanvre
qu'est ce qu'on en faisait à l'époque on
en faisait du film on ne faisait des
tissus des voiles et on se retrouve avec
14 100 92 je vous ramène à l'école vous
me dites
voilà christophe colomb qui part à la
découverte des amériques
s'il a pu re savez-vous grâce à quoi au
voile et au chanvre en effet puisque les
était composé de chambre est également
les cordes et également les cartes
marines et les vêtements
le chanvre est impossible il ne pourrit
pas au contact de l'eau et les rongeurs
meurt en ingérant à cause de la silice
qui a dans sa fibre c'est pour ça que sa
culture et sa coupe est assez délicate
on a donc un peu plus en remontant dans
le temps
cette voiture là
joli modèle n'est ce pas très sympa
fabriqués à l'intérieur on a un moteur
de type diesel que rudolf venait
d'inventer en 1900 il faut des potes
n'existait pas il tournait à l'huile
végétale de chambre tout comme les
lampes à pétrole le pétrole n'existait
pas elle était alimenté avec de l'huile
de chanvre et en rive a eu le génie pour
rendre cette voiture légère de faire une
carrosserie avec de la fibre de chanvre
déjà à l'époque le modèle était léger
résistant on se retrouve quand même avec
un petit problème qu'est ce qui s'est
passé depuis et ben écoutez depuis le
champ d'un disparu
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et
américain venait d'inventer le nylon les
fibres synthétiques
on se retrouve donc avec en 1936
l'interdiction de cultiver du chanvre en
europe
tax act qui a été mis en place par la
foule l association atatra
aujourd'hui du nylon du coton un petit
peu de chance par ici et qu'il ya
également quelques fous qui se pendit
refaisant du vêtement les fous c'est
nous voici la première fois qu'on arrive
en europe à tricoter non pas à tisser
mais à tricoter dans des machines
modernes du chanvre ça cet effet à
quimper cette année
nadon un robot du chanvre qui apparaît
aujourd'hui en bretagne
il n'y a pas que des vêtements un petit
peu de planches de surf
vous avez vu et la plasturgie on se
retrouve avec cette plante qui n'a pas
que du test pas du cbd elle a aussi une
racine
elle a aussi une tige des feuilles des
graines qui contiennent des oméga 3 des
magazines des protéines l'intérieur de
cette tige on se retrouve à copeaux
c'est coppola sont remplies de cellulose
et à l'extérieur le blindage
c'est ça qui va nous faire
le fils de chanvre que nos grands mères
cissé est tricoté voilà la matière
d'autres comment est-ce que nos grands
mères arrivent et avoirs nets pour filer
à leurs qualités presbytes eh ben on va
sur les vieilles photos en bois blancs
elle fumait pas tabac gris caporal des
vieux elle fumait le chanvre
avec ces copeaux de cellulose je vous ai
fait
petit tedx voilà un tedx super léger
résistant qui est imprimé en 3d voilà
vous fait le toucher c'est un matériau
d'avenir peugeot aujourd'hui si mr
renault également fait des carrosseries
avec par contre au niveau des molécules
le c'est aujourd'hui a été comment dire
diaboliser et je pense à raison parce
que 30 % de thc dans des produits qu'on
retrouve au marché noir
je pense que c'est devenu un produit
dangereux aujourd'hui 02 points
aujourd'hui et 3% dans le vieux chambre
à mai mais on n'est plus du tout sur les
mêmes produits à contre au niveau
médicinales l'autre molécule le cbd
grâce aux plantes qui ont été boostées
on a réussi aussi à booster le cbd et ce
cbdc un cannabinoïde on a fait des
études depuis environ 15 ans sur le
sujet 3500 publication autour du monde
aucune en france peu importe on se
retrouve avec aujourd'hui dans le
cerveau des récepteurs spécifiques qu'on
appelle les récepteurs endocannabinoïdes
des récepteurs cb1 et si b2 et dans le
corps tous des capteurs et scott
il n'y a plus de chambre dit
cannabinoïdes depuis un siècle
mais par contre lorsqu'on veut stimuler
le corps on réactive
ces organes là qu'est ce que ça nous
donne
si on a des petites billes blanches le
001 mm ils contiennent les cannabinoïdes
une centaine à peu près qu'on étudie au
fur et à mesure à ces petits bible
hanche qui ont interdit complètement la
culture du chanvre en europe et en
bretagne
c'est un petit peu aberrant par contre
aujourd'hui on est sur des études qui
nous montre des bienfaits pour le
cerveau faut pour les artères pour les
muscles pour les tendons pour les eaux
pour les cartilages pas besoin de fumer
ou même d'un gérer puisque les
récepteurs sont pas tous d'accord avec
des pommades on peut traiter des zones
particulières chez objet de vous parler
de quelque chose c'était alex kahn qui
est le président lutte de la ligue
contre le cancer a donné son feu vert
pour le cannabis thérapeutique c'est
arrivé il ya quelques jours dans les
journaux
les américains ont fait une publication
disant que la cellule cancéreuse va
contaminer les autres
une cellule saine va vous l'avez matin
va s'en aller et ensuite une nouvelle va
prendre sa place le phénomène de
l'apoptose c'est ça qui permet à la
cellule de mourir et de se régénérer
pas facile du cancer ça marche plus si
on stimule certaines cellules avec des
cannabinoïdes et l'apoptose se remet en
place et la cellule cancéreuse en
laboratoire se redit gère
je pense que il y a un avenir certain
sur ce fameux cannabis thérapeutique
ce qui va permettre de relancer à grande
échelle la culture du chanvre des
bienfaits de l'eau de la plante
c'est en cours c'est en route je pense
d'ici quelques semaines
en france on aura des résultats sur le
sujet dans le monde vous savez il ya des
légalisations partout on sait pas ce qui
se passe c'est bien de paix je pense
avant d'agir
maintenant je vais vous parler d'autre
chose des apiculteurs en bretagne il se
retrouve avec l'obligation de racheter
des graines à 0 2 % de thc
tous les ans c'est un coût pour eux
contre quand on a fait nos essais on se
rend compte que cette plante l'a fait 60
cm à peu près en
prat semaine aucune mauvaise herbe
n'arrive
qu'un prédateur pas de demande de
pesticides ni insecticides la seule
plante au monde qui se développe tout
seul sans aucun entretien et qui pousse
en quatre mois à l'époque
regardez une forme poussée par contre
lorsque l'agriculteur récole la plante
la racine pivotante à des compactes ce
qui fait que quand mes humbles et
derrière c'est une tête de cotation on a
10 % de rendement en plus le sol revit à
nouveau avec ces plantes qui n'ont pas
de traitement
vous avez vu le cannabis thérapeutique
c'est pour l'avenir la culture c'est
maintenant et au niveau alimentaire
jeudi la grève va presser la graine on
fait des huiles végétales qu'on trouve
dans les magasins aujourd'hui bio
effectivement on fait des farines avec
ces farines en fait des pâtes
alimentaires ont fait des gâteaux ont
réintroduit aujourd'hui grâce à un
projet pour la planète côte ministère a
lancé du chant dans les écoles et dans
les cuisines centrales 5 me ont été
distribués à quimper il ya un mois et
demi
les enfants on leur explique ont promis
au gallon local c'est du bio ils
finissent tu leur assiette
- déchets on avait vu ça aujourd'hui
les jeunes générations sont prêts à
comprendre qu'est-ce voilà aujourd'hui
ma première vision qui était de
recouvrir la bretagne de chambre
certainement pas parce qu'il va rester
vous savez quoi évidemment qu'est ce
qu'on dit quelques années dans le cochon
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous dire en
conclusion je pense que dans le chanvre
tout est bon on avait un adage avec les
copains quand on a créé l'association
bretagne chambre au développement le
chanvre richesse d'hier le chanvre une
transition pour deux merci
[Applaudissements]